[Music]
in new year new me oh yeah stay me [ __ ]
you're not even you you're MJ why do you
keep talking with your mouth full
she just told you don't eat and then you
chose to still talk
submitted by happy new year drinker oh
yeah I hope you don't succeed in any of
your New Year at all yeah I hate
resolutions but keep going I'll tell you
the detail come on come on rich sugar is
dropping his stage name and would now
like you to call him Brian yeah he's my
friend we talk you know he's been a JK
fan for a long time got B mmm oh really
cuz he doesn't respond to me he's down
to be on taking once I rub it in my face
that you're his best friend
ha he loves you what's up Brian how come
you don't talk back to me back him
you're like three times I leave you
comments what's up doc what's up I
thought we were friends
you're not gonna come on anymore cuz
you're attacking him I'm not attacking
him just jealous yeah Brian you guys oh
you guys I don't know yeah we know Brian
a man you did but there's not a single
person on earth who doesn't know who
this kid is
well there is you're a [ __ ] loser
I like him I'm kidding alright so cuz he
wears fanny packs yeah yeah so he first
made a big with his single called
that stay single with this song called
that thick back in September yes we'll
put them on the map erine yeah yeah 20
she said no you know what I was thinking
I really like I really like how him and
his crew look like kind of like normal
Asian geeks but then there's super
[ __ ] here poppies I'll show you guys
don't know who this guy is here we go
there's a little clip from that song
that got him huge how does your voice
come on like that look at your voice
your voice is good when you rap but he
got mad flow yep
well you know what Haman joji you know
Georgie yeah dope
filthy French I know you out there
filthy Frank he tweeted me a few times
filthy Frank yeah
this will primate this was like 15 or 16
to the US he learned English from
Rubik's cubes videos on YouTube he's
from Indonesia that 4 years ago all
right no 2015 I guess now we're in 18
three years ago well I came out in
September of 2015 so that's it hey you
know Georgia you know Georgie though for
real you know him you know yeah we keep
backing for other all the Twitter's how
come nobody talked to me man what the
[ __ ] you know what it's cuz you hid the
fact that you're Japanese we're so long
you guys gonna connected he's only happy
who's Joe gene Joe Jesus the creator of
the Harlem shake
mean yeah he's the one who creaminess
the first guy that did the [ __ ]
remember is actually a dope rapper dude
he's like unlike some other like weird
[ __ ] come on
so you know if you see kids wearing that
[ __ ] pink bodysuit and [ __ ] yeah
that's his [ __ ] it's pink guy yeah pink
guy and he has like these few characters
and he makes fun of like a lot of like
social norms that are just stupid as
[ __ ] I [ __ ] love this dude man yeah
he's [ __ ] dead he's weird as [ __ ]
he's like someone that like Comedy
Central late-night [ __ ] is like his
habit and you know what sucks though him
and like a lot of the other guys they
got demonetized when it should have been
logan paul he got to monetize well a lot
of his channel a lot of his videos
[ __ ] I like I like I like Georgie
man he's dope man yeah I see the fact
that too too bad none of them want to
talk to me and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
we could have been like awesome friends
and like my two friends here could have
introduced me like my too close for
rands that talked to Brian who's a fan
of JK could introduce me but like now
nothing nothing nothing at all nothing
at all this song was actually released
in March of 2016 apparently like two
years is recorded in 2015 it was
released 26 why is he trying to be like
Brian like the [ __ ] Family Guy dog
yeah so that's his real name that's a
given name well I thought he was trying
to be like the family I don't know his
name was Brian and Manuel and so he was
just saying that
wait his real name's Emmanuel like his
last name or maybe it was like some no
that's not even like a Christian name
either so Manuel though that's his name
and so yeah he tweeted out on January
1st saying yes I now go by Brian I have
been planning to do this forever and I'm
so happy to finally do it I was naive
and I made a mistake new year new
beginning happy new years that's dope so
pretty much he's just saying like you
know chigga it's disrespectful it's kind
of like putting Chinese and the n-word
together and so you're just like yeah I
was young and dumb like I didn't really
realize he pretty much said this uh when
he was being interviewed back in May
with genius he said quote I was
basically trying to make people less
sensitive to the word the N word and
making the word taking the power out of
the word but then I realized like I'm
totally not in a position to do that I
was like I [ __ ] up I don't think he
[ __ ] up we have a video called chicken
honey that was our first video but I
think back then it was different yeah
people are more sensitive culturally
these days
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] see it does make sense
though because he's not asian-american
yeah he's his experience is different so
for him he doesn't have that position to
use the word you guys like what do you
guys feel like you would still use that
word well I think for me like III
relates them from a different
perspective like it's 2018 now and if
people call me uncle sound like I feel
like that was like a moniker I use for a
specific reason for
Pacific character so how I relate to him
it would be like hey my name is Brian
and I made this song for this character
but that song blew up but then Richard
there's just one of my many
personalities that I have and I'd rather
be known as Brian like that's how I
would like believe cuz I wouldn't even
call me Uncle Sam like I definitely
Stovall hey what's up man but I feel
like Uncle Sam is one little facet of
part you know he's really Brian yeah I
changed my name to you know that I know
you do t [ __ ] [ __ ] me right oh he
said Joe came out my turn and in real
name so now he has to become I think he
did a first though I know I first
started on my Twitter and I was like you
didn't what Oh someone like added you
and then I kind of like low-key panicked
because I didn't know you came out I
thought I got hacked and then I'll
thanks for giving your friends a heads
up this is what I do back at we all I
told Bart thinking that he will tell you
why would you why would you think I know
I keep making a mistake mom and I was
like dude I Loki panicked and he's like
no no I checked our YouTube channel
first before hitting you up oh my god
but I think we wait I think I even told
Casey like we were all talking together
and I was like yeah I think I'm gonna
make it all you know together and then
because all of my names were just
different I had your overdose overdose
uncle chin whatever right so now now
it's all together and I feel like we're
in a different time now so I'm like
Brian like it's a different time now you
know I mean like there's no overdose see
does it feel now like now that like
you're totally liberated I feel like um
it's really fun that I can start talking
about like my past experiences yeah
because some of the stuff like I had to
I couldn't really get deep into because
it's like if I want to talk about my
upbringing my parents like my experience
I had to kind of like not talk about the
Japanese stuff huh yeah at least some
stuff out yeah a lot of stuff out
yeah but now it's cool because I could
talk about my stuff and we could have a
Japan vs. Korea battle yes but you have
a little Korean inside of you 1% yeah
well you have 3% Korean yeah yeah
you won't let anyone forget about 1%
Mongolian Wow but almost everyone does
yeah Genghis Khan yeah I think recently
got his jazz Mongolian - no not
Mongolian what he has like some East
Asian and him I'm like a firm at that
sign I guess
Peruvian see that's the sideways part
Taiwanese what he beats him yeah he's
like part Jewish see or something yep
that's why he's cheapest I did it come
out on 23 me uh no its ancestry why yeah
I gotta try that one - oh he had come
from the results yeah good for Brian
though yeah yeah
he doesn't perpetuate the stereotype
what I do like about him is he looks
like an average asian kid but that voice
does not match his musics don't know
what the [ __ ] he's saying it sounds sick
that should pretty deep he talks about
starvation issues and stuff like that
yeah I want to hear none of that [ __ ] I
just like that
couldn't that music works like that
lyrical [ __ ] that you're trying to hear
like I I don't like this type of music
but I understand what it's for yeah you
got I mean so it's like oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] dope look I'm about to that [ __ ]
but I'm not gonna listen to in the house
I wish he was my friend
let it go he's a fan of you yeah he's a
fan of man that doesn't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]